in saroburi province  and i'm 43.  in thailand a lot of things used to be  way behind compared to elsewhere  and my standard of living wasn't so good  now there are shopping centers and fast  food restaurants and things like that  it's a lot better than it used to be  this region has a lot of industry so  there are a lot of clients  i can earn more here than in other  provinces  unfortunately my job doesn't often leave  me with much time to cook for myself  i'd like to go there and travel on a  river one day  a girlfriend told me how beautiful  america is especially alaska  i'd like to expand my business in the  future and sell more beauty accessories  for women  i hope my business will do even better  then  hello